non
[Musique]
au niveau du rond-point j'y suis depuis
le 16 novembre
moi je m'appelle fabrice chandelier la
solidarité je dirais que c'est la
principale chose qui existe sur le coin
j'ai toujours eu un esprit solidaire et
toute ma vie bon j'ai quand j'ai pu
aider les personnes je les fais
aujourd'hui j'ai le sentiment de
renouveler la même chose mais beaucoup
plus forte celle qu'on avait beaucoup
trop dont d'ailleurs on avait trop de
nourriture on savait que on
n'utiliserait pas on s'organise et avec
le véhicule pour aller rejoindre les
gens qui font les maraudes et distribuer
de la nourriture des vêtements parce que
nous aimons nous amène également des
vêtements
sachant qu'on fait les maraudes pour
aider les gens qui sont dans la rue
c'est c'est éphémère quand même parce
que on espère tous que ça dure rapport
aux 6 ce mouvement
mais malgré tout c'est vrai que nous à
notre niveau bas il ya eu des rencontres
il ya des gens qui ne se connaissaient
pas qu'ils sont rencontrés il ya des
couples qui se sont formés également les
gens qui étaient seuls de leur côté
qu'ils sont rencontrés il y aura je
pense d des groupes de personnes qui se
retrouveront
en dehors du mouvement
[Musique]